No
latte in
the middle of Ohio now you know when
Seinfeld was on and everybody loved it,
guess what was Jews from New York like
this idea that we're so out of touch and
that this culture we've come up with
here is anathema to the rest of the
country.
Like guess what?
This isn't where we are as well.
Real American as everybody else.
And sure there are more liberals here,
you know?
Sure Sir.
We're used to a more heterogeneous
population in New York City than what I
just saw when I was reporting in Maine
last week,
but there was plenty of Latte and we're
not that different and we're not any
less American.
Well matter of.
Sorry about the facts.
Sorry.
That that big science,
which is to say scientists have realized
that if we keep doing things the way
we're doing them,
we are going to end the world.
Sorry.
I mean I wish it weren't so like,
but it doesn't make it
a liberal phenomenon.
I mean I used to just beyond my
comprehension.
The thing I was going to say about the
New York Times is you'll notice that as
much as the president likes to say it's
fake news,
the minute he goes in meets with their
editors,
he says it's a great American treasure,
you know,
I mean it is the paper of record and now
and in fairness,
they did make some mistakes.
They're humans like all that stuff
around the wmds and the and the windup
theory I rapport.
That is serious stuff that happened that
the times got wrong,
that eroded public trust,
but I don't actually think that's what's
going.
I don't think that's what this election
was about.
I mean,
we know for fact that it wasn't.
We know for a fact that there was a very
targeted system for disseminating fake
news.
Long form journalism is the only thing
I've ever done.
Right.
That end writing books,
you know,
I don't know how to be a newspaper
journalist.
I think what they do is incredibly
impressive,
but I'm not trained to do it.
I don't know how to do it,
and they have a different mandate than
we do.
I mean,
their mandate is to attempt objectivity,
um,
and ours isn't,
I mean we are meant to tell the truth
and everything you read in the New
Yorker has been fact checked more than
you can believe.
But the overall story I'm telling in any
given,
no matter what it is,
it's always my version and it's not my
mandate to be,
to be without a perspective.
It's not my mandate to,
to remove myself,
to have the least,
uh,
present authorial voice.
I can't,
that's not my mandate.
My mandate is to try to make it
interesting for the reader while
informing the reader,
you know,
with,
a complete allegiance to accuracy.
But I'm allowed to tell the story
however I want to.
And that's the luxury.
I mean,
that's being a long form.
That's being a magazine journalist and
that's what I love about it.
I'm never,
I'm never endeavoring to make myself or
my point of view invisible.
That's not my mandate.
I'm trying to be subtle about it because
the,
the quieter and sort of,
you know,
the more the,
if I'm sly about it,
that it's more persuasive because you
don't want to feel that someone's
directed you to think this,
that and the other.
You want to feel that,
you think that,
but it's my job to lead you to think
whatever it is I want you to.
I mean,
just there's,
I don't think there's a.
It depends,
depends,
depends how honest the individual
journalist is
and how much and how much allegiance he
or she has to the truth to accuracy,
you know,
I mean,
I am not wed to making every person feel
that their perspective has been
represented.
I'm representing my perspective when I
tell a story,
but every single detail in that story
will be the truth and no little false
hood is okay ever.
And we take that very seriously.